thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to learn
more about how you can take your stem
skills to the next level
it's often said that one person's trash
is another person's treasure and surely
there is no greater proof of that than
the home of our master of microscopes
james
all along the windowsills and
bookshelves are jars and tanks full of
samples gathered from ponds lakes and
oceans and even his cabinets and drawers
and bathroom hold stockpiles of what he
has found to someone who may not know
any better james's house probably seems
messy very very messy but we know better
we know that his unusual decor is a
testament to his dedication to exploring
the micro cosmos countless little worlds
that james has collected and taken care
of and most importantly james doesn't
have a problem sharing space with his
samples
scratch that there's actually one
problem the snails
whenever james brings home his latest
collection his goal is to be able to
watch the organisms inside for a very
long time that's why he takes such care
to give them the sun and water and
nutrition that each tiny little world
needs so that he can watch the
populations of algae and hydra and so
much more grow
but aquatic snails are the slow-moving
godzillas of these worlds dining on just
about anything that is in their path
they chomp away at the unfortunate
creatures that get in their way leaving
a path of destruction in their wake and
worse they reproduce like bunny rabbits
so with very little effort a small snail
problem can become a very big snail
problem a landscape overrun with a
creature that simply does not care about
the human whose treasure it is devouring
into trash
so a site like this one should be a
crisis for a master of microscopes
aquatic snails lay their eggs in a
gelatinous mass which can hold hundreds
of little guys like these squirming in
their developing bodies and shells
depending on the species you might find
these sacks of eggs floating in water or
stuck to plants or maybe even on the
wall of an aquarium but as terrifying as
the prospect of a future filled with
hundreds of new snails ready to eat up
all of james's samples is even he is
ready to admit that
these are kind of adorable they are both
squishy and iridescent an uncommon
pairing made all the cuter with their
beady little eyes
the snail eggs that james finds usually
develop pretty fast sometimes hatching
within a few days of when he stumbles
upon them but this time he was lucky he
was able to catch them right before they
hatched so the embryos were fully
visible but while they might be adorable
now they will not stay that way they
will grow quickly the small pearly
iridescent shell building into the
larger encasements that house mature
snails but let's be upfront about
something there are thousands and
thousands of species of snail and we at
journey to the micro cosmos don't know
enough to be able to identify exactly
what species we're looking at so we're
speaking very generally today snails are
members of the mollusca phylum which
includes oysters clams octopuses and
squids and while not all of those
creatures make shells the ones that do
build primarily with calcium carbonate a
hard mineral that protects the softer
animal within
as we have seen the building of those
shells begins before the snails are even
born and those shells will remain with
their snail until they die
as an embryo the snail grows a
proto-conch which will lay a sort of
foundation for the future shell and
after hatching construction continues as
an organ called the mantle begins to
secrete layers of calcium carbonate that
then crystallize
as more layers are added the shell's
characteristic spiral begins to take
shape
interestingly snail shells almost always
spiral clockwise but they can on rare
occasions produce a counterclockwise
spiral a mutation that researchers were
able to trace to a single gene and if
the shell is broken during the snail's
lifetime it can produce more calcium
carbonate through its mantle to seal up
the cracks
it's clear though from the different
patterns and colors that we can see on
these shells but there's more to the
shell building than just calcium
carbonate the outside of the shells are
encased in a layer called periostracum
made of proteins carbohydrates fats and
pigments that will eventually come to
define the snail's appearance
shells may be a snail's most obvious
feature but there are plenty of other
fascinating things to see as well like
these grains wiggling around inside a
recently deceased snail the organ that
holds them is called the statusist and
it helps the snail understand just how
its body is situated in the space around
them as the snail moves the grains or
statoliths bump up against the walls of
the statuses brushing against little
sensory hairs that send information to
the snail's nervous system so it can
process its shifting position and that
strange texture you see in the middle of
the screen there which looks kind of
like a weird footprint that's actually a
dead snail's tongue or more accurately
it's radula
radulas are a structure particular to
mollusks and while we originally called
it a tongue it's perhaps more
appropriate to refer to the radula as a
membrane covered in rose and rows of
teeth that works with the snail's
flexible jaw as the snail moves it can
use its radula to scrape up algae or cut
up plants which means that this weird
membrane full of teeth this wondrous
utensil that helps the snail eat as it
slowly ambles along the world this is
james's enemy this is the nozzle
attached to the unwelcome vacuum cleaner
that digests and clears up the jars and
tanks that he does not
want to be cleared
but as we said
one person's trash another person's
treasure there are many aquarium owners
who seek out snails precisely because
they will clear out algae and other
small organisms or waste that take over
their tank snails serve an important
ecological function and in these cases
also a practical one maintaining an
environment that supports the growth of
other good organisms
so as the old saying goes one person's
slow-moving godzilla is another person's
fish tank vacuum cleaner
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring this episode brilliant
features hands-on interactive courses in
science engineering computer science and
math and brilliant has recently
increased the interactivity of their
courses in their scientific thinking
course you'll dive into the world of
scientific principles by exploring the
laws of physics and principles of
engineering along the way you'll gain
the understanding and insight needed to
start looking at the world in a
different way the courses are designed
for people of all levels so you can jump
in at any point and work your way to
mastery and brilliant courses are also
available offline using their ios and
android app so if you're traveling or
have spotty internet connection you'll
be able to keep on learning if you're
interested in learning more you can get
20 off an annual premium subscription at
brilliant.org
microcosmos
[Music]
the people whose names are on the screen
right now they are our patreon patrons
they're the people who make it possible
for us to continue sharing with you the
majesties of this tiny tiny little world
that is absolutely everywhere i'm not
saying that james wouldn't have an
apartment full of algae jars if it
weren't for you but your support does
make it easier to explain that to
visitors and if you're interested in
joining these people you can check out
our patreon at patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]